we've got thousands of people in here I
can't believe you all came thank you all
for coming welcome back to Hannity we
continue now with Democratic
presidential candidate Robert Kennedy Jr
I want to go back and this drives me
nuts because I've been making the case
that our current president I don't think
he knows today's Tuesday
he could not sit with me as you are and
have this conversation in my view I
think he is physically weak and
cognitively a mess and nobody wants to
say it except the few of us
I want you to look at this tape and tell
me if you think he's fit for the job
take a look let's go late and lick the
world for mother for each year for
Muslim athletes like Kareem al-jul
and and and Joan shingang shipment
schanger
ban on transvestor Americans transgender
Americans Mr President thank you thank
you thank you very much thank you thank
you
don't go anywhere it's a very exciting
day around here we'll have reaction I
met alone with him just he and I and a
simultaneous interpreter 68 times 68
hours
68 times more than 68 hours
all right God Save the Queen man
[Applause]
thank you very much Mr President we
really appreciate it and we love you
thank you
I might add if I didn't I'd be sleeping
alone
you have to explain I better explain
that some don't talk my wife's a Philly
girl
well we're going to win and we're going
to help we have plans to build a
railroad from the Pacific all the way
across the Indian Ocean
okay
do you believe that he is physically
mentally cognitively strong enough to
lead our country this world is a
dangerous place
Robert F Kennedy Jr Robert Kennedy Jr
you know that this is a dangerous place
is he cognitively strong enough to be
your president
well he's never been very good with
words
on
you know
all right you get an A plus for that
answer is he is he up to the job I how
first of all let me ask how many of you
here think he is not up to the job let
me hear
[Applause]
there's a reluctance for politicians and
you're you're you're a Democratic Party
Guy you said that at the censorship
hearing where they censored you
um
and you've devoted your life to things
you believe in and it's probably hard
for you to say that but do you really
think he's up to the job no but I
wouldn't I'm not reluctant to say that
for partisan reason sure you know I when
I've tried to do nurse campaign
is avoid personal attacks on people
but I I will say I will say whether he's
up to it or not whether he's making his
own decisions
the decisions that are coming out of the
White House are bad decisions right and
you know they uh the Democratic party
does not censor people in my experience
um we're not the party of War we're not
the party of the neocons dictating
foreign policy
We're the Party the middle class and
we're the party of working people and
that's not where the party is anymore
I would tell you
here would be my agenda and I think you
agree on some of these things I want to
secure our borders I believe every
American has the right to be safe and
secure in their town in their city that
means we have to have Law and Order it's
a prerequisite to pursue happiness I
want an economy that is thriving and
opportunity economy where everybody
regardless of where you start in life
can climb that ladder to success I want
a mean tough Kick-Ass killer military
that would serve as a deterrent to any
hostile regime that might have ill
intentions towards us I believe in peace
through strength with all my heart
control our borders all these things
there's I believe that educational
school choice
we agree on these things yeah we agree
on all those things yeah
one area
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else